heading west now to Idaho where a judge
rules Lori valadebell's upcoming trial
is put on hold as her competency comes
into question Lori valo dabel and her
husband Chad dabell were set to be tried
together in January 2023 the pair faces
charges in connection with the murder of
Lori Ballo dabel's children JJ and Tyler
as well as Chad's day Bell's first wife
Tammy daybell last week Chad daybell
filed a motion to sever his case from
his wife's this week judge Stephen voice
ruled Court proceedings are on hold
until Lori Ballo dabel's competency can
be determined Balo dabel recently made
headlines for lapping during a court
appearance cameras were later banned
from the courtroom
Catherine yet another delay for a second
competency hearing do you think Lori
dabel is abusing the judicial system
what is she doing here how can she say
again that she is not competent or this
is coming into question yet again
it's hard for us to determine if she's
really taking advantage of the system
here because one the Motions the records
are sealed and heavily redacted for
obvious reasons of protecting her mental
health records and privacy she is also
entitled to a fair trial here and that
includes the constitutional right to be
competent to stand in trial and the the
rule is or the standard is that she's
competent to stand in trial if she can
she's able to understand the character
and consequences of the charges against
her and to be able to help with her
defense now just the issue of her
competency even if she is found in
confident it doesn't mean that she is
blood free she will still be determined
if she will be committed to to
um a jail or a hospital so being
evaluated as incompetent to stand in
trial does not necessarily mean that
she's good to go no she still stays in
jail or is committed to a hospital so it
doesn't do her any good yeah that
actually leads me to my question for you
Bernardo look this is the second time we
delayed it for so many months because
she was trying to determine whether or
not that she was competent that's what
they were doing and now they're going to
do it again what if she's found not
competent again how long could this go
on
is not determined to be competent then
by law they cannot proceed with trial
with her what's going to happen in this
case is that the prosecution is going to
have to make a decision whether they
want to move forward with Chad day Bell
and and go forward with those charges
and then try Lori validate but whenever
is determined that she's confident to
proceed excellent thank you both for
being here and thank you for joining us
on learn crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
foreign